c'était il ya un mois la belgique
retrouver un semblant de liberté et les
bruxellois se retrouver dans les parcs
aujourd'hui ces images paraissent très
lointaine avec un nombre de
contaminations qui a doublé en une
semaine
le pays a dû durcir ces restrictions
fermeture des écoles à part les
maternelles de tous les commerçants dits
de contact et interdiction de se réunir
à plus de 4 personnes dehors un serrage
de vis obligatoire pour le premier
ministre belge
donc le comité de concertation a opté de
prendre des mesures d'une façon forte et
compte et d'opter pour une pause de
pâques une période de quatre semaines de
mise sous cloche avec des mesures qui
sont larges et qui comptent sur la
solidarité des différents secteurs des
mesures qui font polémique chez nos
voisins au point que le tribunal de
première instance de bruxelles a
condamné l'état a levé ses restrictions
sous 30 jours
l'espagne pense elle aussi pour de
nouvelles mesures mais plus limitée la
semaine sainte de pâques sera très
surveillé mais l'espagne reste plus
tempéré avec l'ouverture des bars et
restaurants en allemagne la situation
est plus indécise après l'instauration
d'un confinement de cinq jours pour pack
anglais la merkel a vite abandonné le
projet suite au mécontentement du pays
la chancelière ne comptent tout de même
pas en rester là
nous devons maintenant mettre en place
les mesures appropriées avec beaucoup de
sérieux
or certains états le font d'autres ne le
font pas encore
je ne vais pas rester deux semaines sans
rien faire c'est mon serment c'est mon
devoir
pour d'autres le bout du tunnel à part
est confinée depuis trois mois
l'irlande a annoncé un assouplissement
de ces mesures à partir du 12 avril
le gouvernement envisagerait même une
réouverture des commerces non essentiels
à partir du 4 mai prochain
le voisin anglais à l'aise lui aussi ces
mesures boris johnson a annoncé la
réouverture des commerces non essentiels
dès le 12 avril
et à peine le temps d'appeler la
prudence que plusieurs groupes s'amasser
dans le pays pour fêter la fin du
confinement